if you did a book The Cover is half the
page Trump after Page Kennedy okay John
what do those two families have in
common you just kind of go through it to
see The Good the Bad the Ugly the
corrupt anything that you want to go
investigate the link to Kushner family
all this other family
if you see whatever family didn't need
money is the family that typically
cannot be controlled whoever can be
moved by money I mean you realize bidens
are doing what they're doing for a
million dollar check you realize how
pathetic that is that you can buy
bideness for a million or 10 million
dollars you know what 10 million dollars
is to some of these guys I want 10
million dollars I can buy your family
for 10 million bucks and the big man's
gonna get the big guy's gonna get 10
percent
I I I think it's
it's concerning to put somebody like
that in power so I do think there's a
few people there we'll see what's going
to happen with that what are your
thoughts on that
well you know when it comes to someone
like Joe Biden I think there's a clip of
him that was going around in the primary
he was saying something like
um you know I wanted to be a politician
sooner but I had to wait to be old
enough so I could like sell out properly
something like that who said this um
Biden but this was like in the a long
time ago in the when he was much younger
um you know because apparently they want
to take him seriously when he was too
young or something and he had to wait
I don't know I mean the American
political system the way it has operated
for decades rewards Behavior like that
you know and the problem is how do we
shift it away so it doesn't reward that
behavior and if you're looking at like
we mentioned earlier the DNC is going to
stop debate essentially to shoehorn
Biden in after they've done two
successive presidential primaries where
they essentially committed fraud to keep
the popular candidate out
how Democratic is that you know and I
mean all this other stuff going on all
this funny games to try and like stop
Trump or you know
influence elections I love this stuff
that's I love the fact that RFK is in it
now that you brought him up I love the
fact that vivex in it I love the fact
that Trump's in it I love the fact that
the scientists even what he's doing
right now with the protecting the
conservative values and he's pissing a
lot of people off uh and I love the fact
that Tulsi is also around I hope Tulsi
does something as well there's enough
people that are not of for by the way
Tulsa is going to be on the podcast this
Saturday Saturday Saturday she's going
to be on the podcast so she's another
person that's uh out there going out
there and you know calling people out we
need more people like that and they're
from all sides rfk's running as a
Democrat
you know uh uh Tulsi I don't know what
she's going to be doing whether she runs
as an independent or republican she's
also a necessary voice vivec is sitting
there taking a completely different
angle on the ESG and the woke side you
know and then Trump's doing what Trump
is doing the center is doing what he's
doing more of these voices exposing them
no I'd be curious who's gonna say
specifically Epstein's list well I I
don't know but I think the more rhetoric
of raising awareness of what's going on
whether it's ESG or Epstein or whatever
is important because it's it's really
really really important that a large
enough percentage of the American public
realizes something is seriously
seriously wrong because if we wait too
long and people don't figure it out
things could get much worse than they
necessarily need to be you know
and I would just really hope that
um you know that's what my hope with the
the upcoming campaigns are of all this
with with these different voices a lot
of whom are already coming out and being
very you know anti-system at least in
the rhetoric and that speaks to the fact
that a lot of people in the public are
very hungry for that type of rhetoric
and so that does give me uh hope that
people want a real change not just like
an Obama hope and change hopium uh type
of solution you know because that
we found out later that this whole
cabinet was picked by my Lake City group
and Wall Street right after the 08
crisis and stuff you know troubling
stuff so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]